Contining
[Silence]
where we left off with regards to the
narration of
when she related created the most
comprehensive most complete
story
detailed account
of the first time the prophet Muhammad
Sam
was visited by Gabriel
in
a mountain a cave that is in one of the
mountains just in the in part of
Mecca.
And
narrates to us this narration
and she began by telling us as we
mentioned last time Sunday evening
before yesterday night before last.
She began by describing the first waves
of preparation that ushered in the
meeting between the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam and Gibl for the
first time.
Revelation is a very strenuous process.
It's not easy.
It's difficult for the human being
physically and mentally and spiritually
and emotionally
to receive revelation from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam as were the rest of the
prophets and messengers.
They were built and perfected and honed
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
specifically for this task.
And so for this reason the prophets and
messengers they are human beings.
They are human beings
but they represent the pinnacle of human
strength both spiritually and mentally
in their reception of revelation from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. It's not just
something that can begin immediately out
of nowhere. This is something that would
shock the system, would make it very
difficult for a person to be able to
handle this. And so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala prefaced revelation, prefaced the
first verses of the Quran with a period
of premonition
in which the prophet sallall.aii
described.
[Silence]
She said that when he would sleep, he
began to see premonitions in his in his
sleep.
And when he would wake up, these things
would occur exactly
as he saw in his sleep. As vivid as the
morning dawn, as the break of dawn, as
the morning sun, unmistakable. It's not
just a vague thing that he would see
sallall.aii wasallam and get a and get a
a you know a mild sensation of deja
vu. No, this is fullon premonition
and so his heart is not only alert and
conscious while he is asleep but what he
sees in his sleep becomes relevant. Now
everything that he sees in his sleep is
something that is a revelation from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Now how long
did this happen? This were this is the
beginning stages of his of his heart
being awakened by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
How long did this last? Well, the
scholars discuss the period in which he
would have these premonitions. How long
did it last? A year, 2 years, 3 years, a
day or two, a week or two?
There's nothing
absolute
from the authentic narrations of the
prophet sallall.aii
which tell us of exactly how long this
took place.
However, in Muslim, the prophet
sallall.aii
am said
he said sam
that a righteous premonition
a righteous premonition
someone sees something in their sleep
and then it happens as they saw it. This
is referred to as a
there's a difference between a and a and
the prophet sallallam
he categorized what a person sees in his
sleep into three categories which we
will mention inshallah.
But he said that the righteous
premonition
is one of 46 parts of prophethood. Now
notice the wording there that the
righteous premonition
is one part of 46
parts of prophethood. This narration is
inah Muslim.
46 parts.
Meaning that one part is premonition and
then there are 45 other elements and
parts that make up his pro his prophecy
and his prophethood sallall.aii
wasallam.
But when we look at, as some scholars
have posited,
when we look at the number of years that
he was a messenger and a prophet, how
long was he a prophet and messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam?
[Arabic recitation]
46.
And so
some of the scholars have mentioned that
this time, this period that ushered in
that revelation of Ramadan, that this
was about 6 months. This period was
about 6 months long before he finally
received revelation sui
based on these narrations. Of course,
is defined as something that a person
sees in his sleep and occurs exactly as
he sees it.
But a person sees many things in their
sleep.
And the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
divided these things into three
categories. We could call them dreams.
But these dreams, this word is a very
vague word because in the sunnah
a righteous premonition is only referred
to as a premonition as a
it's never referred to as a dream by the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. He said in
that what a person sees in his sleep is
of three types. One is a premonition a
righteous premonition.
Two is
a from aan
which is a dream that comes to him from
aan. What is the what is the measure of
what is from a shaan? If it causes a
person extreme anxiety, fear or it is
nonsensical
or it in elicits bad thoughts about
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala or paranoia
or causes a person to think ill things
about Allah or his messenger or those
around him. This is referred to as what?
Am
the third type is
not a a helm is you know forbearance but
a
the third type is
I keep saying because that's how we
speak in my dialect right we seem but
it's actually in proper Arabic it's the
third type is hadiths
You go to sleep thinking about
something. Something's weighing heavy on
your mind. The subconscious
springs forth while your conscious is at
rest. Right? This here has no
interpretation really.
Once a man and sah Muslim and what we
see in our dreams is important or in our
premonitions or in our sleep. It's
important. It is not as important as
many people make it out to be. Right? So
for instance, let's say in our entire
community, in our entire entire local of
Tucson here, all of the Muslims
collectively there's no scholar amongst
them that is able to interpret dreams.
Right?
Is there any haram
upon us for not having that? No, it is
not considered to be.
It's something which is a science to be
learned from the scholars of Islam.
But it's given a lot more weights with
people than it should have. Some people
they go to the ends of the earth to
interpret some dream when really if a
person had a had a a vision and they
were never able to get a an
interpretation for it and they didn't
know what it meant and they weren't able
to make heads or tails of it. What's the
worst of that? Nothing.
Because our guide truly is the Quran and
Sunnah but it's something preferable to
have.
However, the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam he gave attention to visions,
premonitions.
he usually would sit to interpret
the visions of the companions
after
and most usually on the morning of J.
So he would make he would lead the
companions in prayer and then he would
turn to them and if he had a premonition
that is extremely important because that
is revelation
from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala or if any
of the companions had
seen something they would tell him
and he would interpret these things for
them if they have an interpretation
right and I'm saying this leading up to
something in Muslim a man told the
prophet Sam
and
he said I saw in my sleep that my head
got cut off and I started chasing after
my head trying to catch it. What was the
prophet's response? Now, many of us, we
would hear this and we think, "Wow,
that's that's very, you know, profound.
That must mean some kind of thing,
right? You ask some kind of psychiatrist
or psychologist and they'll give you
some Freudian interpretation of what
this means, right? Because everything in
Freud's world, Sigman Freud's world,
breaks down to the desire for
reproduction.
Right? The sexual drive that's the
meaning of all of existence in his
perverted world and this has leaked
itself and seeped itself into the Muslim
psyche as well. Many of our Muslim
brothers, not to bash psychology, there
is some relevant knowledge there. But a
Muslim psychologist who does not learn
the sunnah of the messenger sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam and learn the Quran and
specifically the interpretation of
dreams will be a very a very weak and
you know person in his profession.
And then you look at this kind of
pseudocience and it's every bad
thing that a person does or has or every
bad habit, it's all this pseudo
holistic excuse. Oh, that's because in
your childhood you felt feelings of
abandonment.
So that's that's why he cuts people off
in traffic or that's why he refuses to
take the trash out on time, right?
Because in his childhood, his father
raised his voice at him and it shook him
to his core, right? Or he saw a rat run
through or he lived with cockroaches or
whatever. Everything has to do with your
childhood. As if as adults, we are
automatons that do not have the choice
to be what we want when we grow up. As
if you are nothing more than the product
of your childhood. and find some way
that your mother and father failed you
so you can put the blame on them and
continue to be what you want. This
doesn't work this way. This is a very
small part of how a person behaves as an
adult especially after he has been
awakened by the Quran and the Sunnah of
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam. The point
here is that this man said I saw my head
cut off and I started chasing my head.
It sounds very profound. This hadith is
in Sah Muslim. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam responded.
He said, "Don't tell people about the
games is playing in your head while you
are asleep." Meaning that this vision is
nothing but a dream. It's just whispers
from a shaitan. Imagine that you had
this dream at night that you were
sleeping. You had a dream that your head
got cut off and you were chasing your
head and you couldn't catch it. How
would you feel? That feeling is the
indicator that this thing that you saw
in your sleep is from a shaitan.
This is the difference between that and
a righteous premonition. a premonition
from Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala which is
one of 46 parts of prophethood
and so this period that prepared his
heart for that ultimate meeting with ji
which we will discuss which night it was
in Ramadan inshallah this was about 6
months leading up to this which means
that this first began And in which
month? Who could tell me?
How many of us here know which month
they were born, which day and month they
were born in the Hijri calendar?
Have you ever even thought about it? We
don't think about it. We have been so
profoundly colonized
both both mentally, emotionally,
psychologically.
just doesn't occur to us. And I'm not
saying this to shame anyone, but we come
from countries that have been ravaged by
colonialism.
Our dean and our identity has been
stripped away from us. Some of us, even
our Arabic language, places Algeria
and Tunisia and Morocco barely could
speak Arabic anymore because the
colonization was so intense.
Anyways, we will complete this inshallah
tomorrow night. We'll pick this up.
we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
grant us understanding of the Quran and
Sunnah to grant us knowledge of what
Allah has sent down upon his messenger
Muhammad sallall.aii Wasam and that he
make us of those who hear the truth have
the enlightenment to identify the
truth when we hear it and have the
courage to adhere to that truth.
While early he was
alhamdulillah.